all right I can't say this title how do
you say it
the in Kyrie dia in KY Rhydian okay I I
forget even what the book does I just
remember it shows him like it explains
how to kiss princesses against kids in
four instances is different from kissing
other girls so what did the book do
again I forgot basically it's like the
ultimate book for adventurers okay yeah
it's like in a sense if you will tips
and tricks on how to do anything and
there's also other stories of it's like
me at Jones handbook okay so he has to
go and he doesn't have to he just likes
going on these adventures because he
apparently the name that shows adventure
time so bada-bing he has like an
addiction I'm noticing more and more
just like it I it's it's like we're
going to the factories looking furniture
and wonder like he's pounding the ground
and stuff so I kind of like that I like
how like kind of insane he is about
something so innocent and they go up
they gone does the veteran and the two
things that I really remember in this
one the one is the the key guy who I'm
guessing that's the micromachine yes
well what I like about that is that they
obviously use his talent that he can
talk very fast but he's doing a voice as
well I really like that I like it's not
just oh a micro machine man doing his
thing is like no sooner has this little
voice and he's gonna talk fast like that
that's hilarious
um and he has the giant key on his head
which of course everyone figures out how
to open the door he never realizes how
they figure it out and is devil pajamas
DFW jammas no I just you can't devil
pajamas we should get and because
everyone goes to bed with a Triton - and
what was the of oh the were those trolls
that they saved our little fairies or
what were those gnomes gnomes okay the
he saved these gnomes from like a pool
of fire which is already like so violent
but then it gets like much worse it's
like that because there are you guys
good now we're gonna kill ladies and
they just start blowing up old ladies at
random it's like every and every time
nobody's gonna do is like every time you
see what we're gonna blow up another old
lady one Oh
every time you say no we're gonna blow
up no about what no boom and it's just I
was watching that like how the hell are
they getting away with this this is a
freaking you know at first we were like
in the last episode like oh no they said
sexy it's a little risque now they're
blowing up old ladies but I guess the
way that got round is they just said
it's an illusion right don't they pop up
at the end again yeah and then one like
what he does his little fries logo at
the end another one disappears is that
like does that come into play later I
will say at this point in time perhaps
now that you said I'm just looking for
like everything though I didn't locate
the snail uh now in the commets agapi
million people like the snail was here
so yeah that's the best part about the
show at least for partially for me it's
that yeah you don't catch a snail on
your first viewing or your second
viewing or maybe even your third viewing
but there are so many things in the
background that's going on that like
even when Yuri watch it you're not
watching what's mainly going on you're
catching all these neat little things in
the background it always seems like it's
really crowded oh there's always like a
lot of weird creatures there and now I'm
just looking at like well is that gonna
come back cuz they're gonna come back is
that anomaly questioning everything even
though I haven't seen anything come back
yet really but just I'm like trying to
be ahead of the game but I get that's
the nice thing I don't think you can be
ahead of the game with this show by any
means it's really really really
difficult
anyone could actually predict everything
that's gonna happen the show there in
like a mental institution or like stoned
off their ass or something because yeah
there's like no way this anyone could
predict it so yeah I mean and what was
that thing that had the head like the
the cloak over its face and the red eyes
and stuff does that have a name or no no
at least if he does I've never heard it
okay thing and it's that thing was
pretty cool and I sort of like the idea
of like whatever kill this monster was a
very creative design firm right yeah
sir well it wasn't like two hearts are
like a heart and a liver or something
something like that then there was like
almost tentacles and there was a
skeletal glowing hand
yeah I'm pretty out there creator which
I like though that like you know kill
this EDS is it an evil and which is just
a great question in general amazing no
it's evil it's not good it's neutral
destroy it and again to the characters
credit I like this like now I want this
try a neutral hands in here
I guess he takes that guy in the grind
to death guard kicking ability yeah like
he just literally banishes after that oh
the artichoke I'll see real fast I
really really liked was the the manatee
or manotaur what's a cold again
manly Minotaur manly Minotaur who comes
and when he flexes his muscular arms
have muscular arms and then that was
great like that's a really inventive
joke
so aside from that but the only other
thing I'm noticing with this show that's
kind of neat and maybe one of the few
shows that I've seen pull it off is that
the show has a way of being both
disgustingly cute and revolting at the
same time like you can look at the exact
same design and go ah or go oh no you
can't it's just whatever you see in it
and I like that I like you concerned do
that combo because when I first started
off I didn't like the design of the show
hmm that's one of the reasons I didn't
get into it especially because like dot
eyes yeah I don't like in things I ve
ever mentioned before but like I think
Calvin Hobbs could do it and Animaniacs
could do I've never seen any other show
make it interesting
yeah but they can't cheat with a bit
they'll give them like realise or like
at one point I'm ready got angry and hit
like three dot
and he said cuz it's that crazy so so
the Cal work within have fun with it
what do you think it's kind of cool um
but yeah that's that's about it I can
think for this one any other tidbits
that do you think should be mentioned
about this one one thing I really enjoy
about this one is so Finn is going after
the in Caribbean which is the ultimate
adventurers handbook and at numerous
times he kind of says screw the handbook
I'm gonna do this because they hear the
help and Jake is like oh what about the
book and he's like not now
okay yeah that shows which gets in the
blog exactly it shows that he's not just
concerned with this he's more concerned
with being a good person over just
getting this all-powerful book which is
great and then along those lines
the enchiridion that comes into play
later uh well I had a feeling that one
thing I'm like well okay I know they
gotta do something else with this if for
any a reason the design of the book is
way too good that becomes a major player
if you will okay no that'll be
interesting I'll serve I was hoping it
would cuz it's like oh this is like it
just has a lot of fun possibility like
the adventurers handbook it just sounds
like a fun book to own in general yeah
you know I even just how to kiss
princesses it's like that's just a funny
chapter it's a oh what else is in here
I'm like that how to run away from a
giant ball of chasing yours if there's a
lot of things they can do so yeah Oh
before I forget I want more off your
podcast because I don't know how many
people know it okay what you want me to
say say the podcast and where they can
listen to a dumbass oh sorry
it's the forced viewing podcast it's at
force viewing calm and it's available on
iTunes it's available on iTunes this is
what someone gear someone coaching you
there yeah yeah I don't do this very
often and I've been a few of them to
I've been in the fourth viewing also
what's in the skull yeah so if you
haven't seen that check it out they
talked about not Adventure Time yet yeah
but maybe you will maybe well next time
or may you be still Signet talking by
the end of today maybe I'll just I don't
think you could get second up in the
more thing about know okay so oh the
show this show is great
you'll see more in the next one take
care